hello folks and
welcome to rational science
today i have a little bit of a problem
with my eye i don't know what happened
sometime in the morning uh it it started
hurting
and it's not the eye i think it's the
eyelid
and it started hurting for no reason
whatsoever right at the corner right
there my right eye
so if you see me squing squinting or
blinking a little too much today you'll
know what's going on i put some drops a
little while ago maybe it smooths out
the
the problem anyway if any of you know
anything about that had the same
experience maybe you
can tell me something about it really
appreciate it
okay we're going to do a first
extinction
then we're going to follow that up with
physics we're going to do today
magnetic lines of force what are
magnetic lines of force
we can't see them we can't touch them
what are they are they real are they
or are they uh spirits
what what other what are those lines of
force okay maybe we'll find out today
and then at the end i'll open the floor
for questions that people have
asked since last time okay let's get on
with it uh
someone asked uh regarding the
sentinelese
okay he spelled it wrong so i hope he
corrects that next time
uh these are people who live a lost
tribe so to speak
uh that lives in even today
in a uh little island known as sentinel
island that's why they're sentinelese so
island that belongs to india it's in the
indian ocean between
india and uh thailand
and vietnam those countries over there
somewhere in between those
two regions it's sentinel island and we
have these people that live there
they're maybe only 150 200 people that's
all that's left
and there were like 3 000 of them
[Music]
in the 19th century so they've lost a
lot of
folk a lot of members in the tribe
and maybe they're on their way out aside
from the fact that they probably lost
uh quite a bit of genetic diversity okay
and so um this is what i'm talking about
i talked about it the other day
apparently sometime around 60 000 years
ago that's the
theory uh some black people
left africa and that's why these people
are black
because apparently they had their origin
in africa
and they uh the theory is that they went
along the coast and somehow ended up in
australia
and a group of them somehow ended up in
that
where you see the circle there that's
where the sentinelese
sentinel islands are at there's a north
and a south one
and these folks live in north in the uh
north sentinel island this is what that
island looks like
from uh you know a bigger picture of it
there and uh so again there's a few
people who live there
and are protected by the indian
government in great measure because a
lot of people want to
go over there you know and talk to the
sentinelese and so on
but the sentinelese are very violent
people
they kill anyone who comes to their
island and nobody holds it against them
because they say well these people live
out there in the wilderness they do
hunter gathering
you know they don't know anything about
civilization
and here here's a picture of these uh uh
you can call them indians because they
are truly indians today they're
citizens of india without passports or
any
documentation but this is a more or less
what they look like on that island
and you can see the bottom left one
there they're shooting at a helicopter
they're shooting arrows that they they
probably don't even know what that is
you know
how's that big bird flying out there
anyways these uh
folk are not very friendly uh for
whatever reason
and um again they're being protected by
the
indian government so what's the issue of
foul asks a question or
made a series of comments and questions
here he says
might have lost genetic diversity long
before and yet they are surviving even
now
yeah they're very likely low on genetic
diversity
okay but i suspect that
if we took their dna uh
we would find that they're very similar
to humans today
even though they would probably be you
know on the
outskirts of our uh jeans uh they're
still very close to us i think
uh simply because of how many thousands
of years they've been around
and my my take on this that these uh
sentinelese they don't date from 60 000
years ago
again this is my personal view on this i
think they uh
they probably occupy those islands a lot
more recently maybe
in the neolithic that's that's my guess
anyways uh says in the last videos uh
you said there might be some pockets
here and there he's talking about
pockets of humans that might survive on
the planet
once the uh global economic collapse
happens which is my
theory for the extinction of man i'm
saying that
the global economy is going to collapse
when that happens
not if but when um
no one's going to produce or distribute
food and most of humanity will die
that's my take on that and i
i think that some pockets of people will
survive
here and there on the planet they'll be
very few and far apart
okay when that happens um and so yeah
so what happens uh when that what
happens when that happens what happens
afterwards okay
and uh this was talking about the
sentinelese he said they might have
killed dryden kept humans
for later consumption uh no i don't
think so i don't think you see they
they've killed a couple missionaries in
fact a few months ago that's what how i
heard about the
the sentinelese they killed a missionary
that's how they came into
the news uh at least from my point of
view
and um and what they did apparently they
buried
that human they don't need human they're
not cannibals as far as
we know okay and he continues and they
would rape women with them and they are
not
even if they are not willing partners
you know anyone who survives uh you
shouldn't be talking too much about rape
i don't i don't think they're gonna have
time for sex
as much as for something more pressing
which will be
subsistence farming they'll be producing
food
okay and people have this mind you know
stuck on
this day and age where everybody can see
sex
online and uh there's uh you know
they're they're into
a lot of sex um playboy
uh hustler and so on
you know after the collapse there's
going to be no sex at least for
reproduction reproductive sex
which is what this fellow has in mind
there won't be any sex in that sense
they might have sex of course but i
don't think they'll be thinking too much
about sex they'll be more worried
about um food about producing food
there'll be very little time very little
energy
to have sex whenever they do have sex
they're probably gonna be a lot
more philosophical than we are about
today because they're going to be
thinking about
all the all the humanity that departed
i think that's going to be on their mind
they're going to be
probably remembering the old days and
then
for sure if they have sex it will not be
reproductive
sex mainly because the females will not
want to
have a baby you're talking about city
folks here primarily
that might survive and they're not going
to have babies without doctors without
hospitals without anything like
like we used to in the old days you know
in a cave i'm not sure how many women
will want to do that
that's one issue the other one is that
even if they do
decide to have sex or they have an
accident and
become uh pregnant uh and they do have
the kid
it's not like they're gonna restart the
race it's not gonna be an adam and eve
situation because on the one hand they
lost their genetic diversity
meaning that three or four generations
later it's the end of humanity anyways
you know who knows what's going to come
out of there and second it's not going
to balloon it's going to be
it's not going to be exponential
reproduction
if anything they have one and that's it
and that's the last human on earth
it's going to be like that okay so but
again this fella has it the other way
around he says that way they can survive
and probably
increase in number as their population
pyramid will be of normal shape
absolutely not their their population
pyramid will
simply be more uh pronounced uh
in uh in the sense that more folks will
be old and very few will be young
they will we will not be reproducing we
will not be producing children okay
not not in quantities if anything won by
accident but
not deliberately who's that fella going
to marry i don't know if there's only 10
or 20 in the group
you know it's not like they can produce
a hundred out of there
more than likely you're gonna have a uh
already
a uh an inverted pyramid population
pyramid
in that group and the only thing they
can do by accident is produce
fewer children which will in the next
generation produce even fewer
children the fellow says well okay if
they can increase in number they are
at least two communities that can uh
meet after a few millennia
okay provided they survived till then
they would have two different gene pools
uh again you know first of all these
pockets will be few and far apart
they will not have children they will
treat
another group as enemies if they're too
close together
okay more than likely they'll be so far
apart and too worried about producing
food
that they will not be thinking about
going to so far away from where they're
at
to see if there's other humans out there
they're not going to venture too far
apart
far from their camp okay so you know i
think this fella has
uh most of the stuff upside down he's
thinking in terms of today and maybe in
the days of
adam and eve you know paleolithic this
could be totally different
this is going to be you know if if they
survive it's because they're planting
and not because they're hunting i don't
think there's going to be any hunting
there's going to be nothing to hunt
after most humans are wiped out
by hunger they're just going to kill
every animal in sight
and whoever survives will have to depend
on planning
and that means they had to plan in a
head
in advance uh in order to plant in the
future
okay that's one issue the other one is
that uh they're gonna be so busy
with subsistence farming and taking care
of you know the their food
supply for the next winter or next
summer
that they won't have time for a lot of
this other stuff uh
like going out there and looking for
other people so
and even if they do uh remember one
thing
uh whoever survives will already have uh
exhausted uh we'll start out with uh
exhausted genetic diversity now there's
gonna be no genetic diversity
we already have none among humans today
and here let me give you um
an example of that okay here it is uh
came out in 2012 but there's
been a couple reports on that and also
sets of data out there it says
chimpanzee populations listen to this
troops
that's what they're called these
chimpanzee populations
living in relatively close proximity are
substantially
more different genetically than humans
living on different continents
okay if you take the entire human race
eight billion of us we're down about
every one of us
maybe the sentinelese will be an outlier
in that
group okay but if you take all humans
today
we are all brothers and sisters from a
genetic point of view there is no
we're all clones we're all clones anyone
who you marry today you married your
sister or your brother
okay from a genetic point of view that's
how close we all
are all of us so um
you know right now if a pocket from that
group survives they're not gonna their
genetic diversity is not gonna
increase it's gonna if anything decrease
okay so uh keep that in mind
we cannot we cannot increase our genetic
diversity
any more and uh that's a long story
i have a graph that shows that but i
talked about it in the past uh i'll
bring it up
some other time i got it also in my book
the neanderthal book
but the issue is you cannot increase
genetic diversity
and the main reason there you need a
different environment
to create genetic diversity we don't
have it
we can't have it anymore even if you go
to the north pole you're gonna
you're not gonna go with your skin
you're gonna put something on that means
you're gonna bring your uh environment
with you
so you're not gonna change and it takes
thousands of years to change anyways
so it's not going to happen anyways and
it's never going to happen again
we can only lose from now genetic
diversity from now on
so whoever survives whatever pocket
they're already starting on the wrong
foot they're already starting out
without any genetic diversity quite
different than what happened
in the paleolithic or the upper
paleolithic when the neanderthals went
away
about 50 000 years ago really they went
away they say somewhere around 40
000 years ago which is when the
mustarian
technology that they used apparently
disappears
so at that time we had quite a bit of
diversity in our genes and so on but
since then all we've done is lose lose
lose and today we're all clones
okay that's essentially the story and
people say
clones but a black guy from africa and a
yellow guy from the
orient and a white guy from the west
you take our genetic code like i just
showed you there
we're all alike maybe the guy is black
the other guy's yellow though i'm white
you take our genes we're all the same
essentially
there's not that much difference between
us from a genetic point of view
and that's got to do a lot with disease
okay
that's the sifter but i've talked about
that in the past
okay let me continue here uh
one fellow talks about fertility okay
and he says the following he says
fertility
rates were very low before the advent of
agriculture
i don't subscribe to that theory i think
it's the other way around or i make a
different assumption
i'm saying that fertility rates were
very high
the problem was that most of those
children died for different reasons and
humans did not live very long either it
was between 20 and 30 years and they
would die it was a
very short lifespan today we lived to
the age of 70 80 90 100. you know
that wasn't the case you know 40 50
000 years ago no way in fact just at the
turn of the century of the 20th century
the average age 1900 was around 40.
today it's a lot higher it's like 67 or
closer
to 70 maybe okay and that's because some
people live to 100 others people live to
60 or whatever 50
but uh you know the life expectancy of
humans has gone up
dramatically in the last century no
alone
and before that people would die very
young especially
children they would die in fact one
calculation is that
in around 1800 1800
about half of the children half of the
children below the age of five
would die that's how that's how familiar
we were with death
today uh you don't see death anywhere if
you wanna see death you gotta
see someone kill someone or some
accident or something like that
people don't die today okay at least not
we don't see that as common as in the
old days in the old days uh people would
die from disease
okay today nobody dies of diseases we
die of old age
uh ailments you know we can't live
forever
i know that okay what do you think the
mechanism is for people deciding not to
have children it's not that
people know yeah to some degree people
decide not to have children because it's
already in our culture
it's a question of culture of the cities
and there you see the reason density
dependence density dependent birth rates
that's what it's called
and the example that i always try to
give is that when you have
a lot of bacteria or fungi or whatever
in a small space first they multiply you
know like
there you see how they're multiplying
and then
and then at some point they they reach
saturation
and the population pyramid overturns
they don't have enough stuff to eat they
don't have enough space
density has grown too high and at that
point they stopped
reproducing as much as they did in the
past so the first uh
growth is exponential and the decline is
also exponential they finally
succumb to to the amount of space or the
amount of food or
resources and so fell says why do
the cities cause people to not want them
yeah
and again it's got to do with density
dependence i think the numbers were
artificially inflated by the utility of
children before technological societies
made them
obsolete um
yeah it's got to do with the transition
from the country to the city which is
still going on today but essentially
uh what we see today are cities big
cities and what has happened is not that
we produce so many children in the
cities
but that people from the country were
bought out they were living in farms
they had many children they moved to the
city to look for jobs
and today we have all these enormous
cities these aren't
enormous ant holes and the country has
been left in the hands or has been
increasingly
left in the hands of agricultural
corporations
that produce the food that feeds the
cities
that's the the model we have today okay
and here's a the world population okay
you can see how the numbers increased
uh through the ages okay and
uh if you look at it one more time this
is from like
i think the beginning yeah the beginning
of the christian era
and you can see uh how we've multiplied
most of them in the you could say
certain
regions close to the equator not quite
the equator
but you can see that way up north and
way up south
uh there's relatively few people and
then a lot of those
that you see there are primarily big
cities
that's where people are at today okay
and the way i like to look at this is
through a chart
okay and i call it the curve of life
okay
and this explains what this is asking uh
for a long period of time we had
uh births approximately equal deaths so
there were
lots of births but also lots of deaths
for different reasons
then towards uh the en and this applies
to any
species almost practically i mean if
there's any exception there's few of
them out there
most of them will simply be that uh
follow this curve some will be longer
some will be shorter some will be taller
or or
smaller but the point here is that the
shape of the curve applies to almost any
species
and again the first part is births
approximately equal to this just a
little over does so the
population increases very very slowly
then at some point
and this is again towards the end of a
species lifetime okay
births uh start increasing um
being greater than deaths and that's
because
the species has become sedentary
and they get used to endemic diseases
primarily that's the reason
and the the diseases that used to kill
them
in the past no longer kill them they
might make them sick
but most of the population survives
then at some point they reproduce
because now births are greater than
deaths and they reach a point where
again um you know they live longer and
so
deaths now uh become greater than births
and shortly after that we have that both
um deaths and births
uh go down you know their births are
less than death but
uh fewer births and greater great deaths
that's what's happening
and that's what leads to extinction now
you're
probably going to hear out there or see
out there
the s curve the s curve that they have
out there stops at bursts greater
or approximately equal to this which is
that high point there and they say oh
there's your s s-curve
they never finish the s-curve the
s-curve ends
in extinction okay that's my take on
that
okay so whenever you see that the
s-curve
ask them to complete it what happens
after the
upper part of the s i'm saying it goes
all the way down to
extinction for populations okay
okay another fellow ass along the same
line the angiosperms had an effect on
the plankton food supply
uh i don't think so he's asking that
apparently he
was answering someone else okay but
someone else uh
brought another question along the same
lines
and said plankton and conifers have
genetic diversity in common
uh yeah what he really meant i think
okay i don't want to put words in his
mouth but i think what he's saying is
they have in common the fact that they
either had lots
when they started out and very little
when they ended okay that's what he's
saying
he says that more or less in the next
sentence he says they went extinct
because they lost their genetic
diversity
so that's what they had in common and
their population pyramid
overturned and so let me
double up on that okay and so this is
the
notion here the you can say the theory
and i'm gonna look at one example which
is just one food chain which
i've looked at there's others out there
but this one
i think illustrates quite well what
happened
in the cretaceous and this is in the
seas okay you had uh the
plankton that was up to the kt the
cretaceous tertiary
boundary that was large it was large
plankton okay then uh it was
uh replaced by small plankton
after the kt boundary in other words our
era
the era of mammals in the seas we had
small plankton
that replaced the large plankton that
died at the kt
boundary more or less okay moses are
ammonites which are those kurdicus there
uh ammonites fed on plankton
on the large plankton now if they ate
large plankton because the small
plankton were
too little too small fries to eat or
because it wasn't the same region or for
whatever cause
it doesn't really matter the point is
that the uh what this appeared were the
large plankton
the ammonites and the mosasaurs that
entire food chain
went away what survived where the small
plankton for a minifera called also
four amps okay and uh
let me remove this okay and so
here's uh what it looks like okay uh
the the kt plankton and conifers have
in common that population pyramid
overturned okay so that's
uh doubling up on this what this fellow
said
and they both lost genetic diversity
towards the end
and you can see there the differences in
the
foraminifera that existed before
the kt boundary and after the kt
boundary you had the dinosaurs on the
left hand side and the little tiny
mammals on the
right hand side so to speak okay you had
small
[Music]
forums replace big forums that's
essentially what happened in the seas
and the numbers decrease in the last few
million years of the cretaceous that's
what happened to the forams okay so
their numbers started to decrease not
only for the forums but
also for the conifers okay
um the varieties also decreased
okay i'll show that in a second conifers
especially psycheds and cycadio leads
okay uh william sonjas and so on those
were the ones that
disappeared at the kt boundary you can
think of them as
cactus or palm-like
trees okay that's what they look like
and they were crowded out by the
angiosperms which were
dotting the land okay plankton crowded
out by smaller species okay
and again it's very likely that you know
the small plankton
started occupying the same niches as the
large plankton
the large plankton were being eaten up
by the
ammonites which were eaten up by the
mosasaurs
and when they went away and what
remained were the small plankton which
were eaten by fish and
other animals that survived maybe
turtles and zunos
okay here's the cretaceous terrestrial
revolution which
tells us what happened to the conifers
this is on land
okay this is a four year study that they
collected this information so it's a
pretty good graph i think that shows
what really happened and that's about
midway into the cretaceous
you can see the angiosperms are muscling
aside all the other
types of plants that existed until then
the ferns had been muscled aside by the
cycads
somewhere around the turn from the
triassic to the jurassic that's when the
ferns started going away especially the
seed ferns
and the cycads you know the the jurassic
is known as the age of cycads
well they had to come to an end as well
and you can see that hump there the
green one
uh and and the blue one those two humps
uh that's when they turn the corner
about midway into the cretaceous the uh
cycads and the ferns started going away
whatever ferns there were
and the cycads had muscle democide
already
quite a bit and now the angiosperms are
starting
to muscly muscle aside all these other
uh plants
kissing kicking them aside including the
ginkgos okay we only have one species of
that today
biloba and um and i think this explains
in
in quite a bit of uh detail what really
happened and that's that the
mammals grew or expanded radiated with
the angiosperms
and the dinosaurs came in to an end
because the cycads
were coming to an end whatever they ate
and i think it was cycads okay
there there are forests there are
jungles where
uh there were islands that were
shrinking okay so i call it the
shrinking island theory
because uh the islands that uh
fed them were becoming smaller and
smaller and smaller so the
dinosaurs could no longer radiate as
they did in
millions of years before that
there were not as many niches to occupy
they simply settled
wherever they were and they were
becoming fewer and fewer
in quantities and in species number of
species
why because their island was shrinking
and part of the cause of that was the
fact that the angiosperms were expanding
and
occupying the land as far as the
dinosaurs were concerned those were
weeds
and what was expanding with those
angiosperms were the
mammals yeah that's us today okay
okay and uh so what is this about well
it's about uh what i call the
uh first the population pyramid overturn
okay which is followed by the ecological
pyramid
overturn what am i talking about i'm
talking about the fact that for
plants okay um they had to come to an
end at some point in time
they lost genetic diversity and um
eventually they became old and old meant
uh overturning of their population
pyramid
meaning that um the last
plants of these each of these dynasties
that existed until then
they had become old they grew big
they had fewer seeds they probably
grew vegetatively at the end
and well there are several criteria for
determining when a species is old
okay i've gone through that in the past
and that's called an overturning of the
population pyramid
and when that happens the animals that
depend on those
plants and develop the i don't know
millions of years relationship with them
they go as well
and that's what happens at the bottom
you can see that the
what happens is as the green part there
the
overturning of primary production goes
from many to few
the herbivores go from many to few and
the predators
at that point in time they're expanding
at the wrong time taking care of all the
herbivores
which are also suffering because there's
there's less food to go around
so that's what those are the two
mechanisms the first one being
the population pyramid overturned
followed by the ecological
pyramid overturned of the animals
and we have a case uh the mouse utopian
universe uh
carried out by uh john calhoun
a uh i guess he was a
biologist he was a psychologist really
but he studied it
from a biological point of view and then
at the
bottom right you see what happens to
humans our population growth rates have
been going down since
1963 and we cannot stop it
and i'm saying the reason we cannot stop
it and we won't stop it is that
we've come to the cities we don't
produce children in the cities
so that curve shows exactly what's
happening to man right now
we are we are going to approach maybe
around
2050 mid-century
zero population growth and i don't think
we'll ever get there
that's that's my take on that i'm saying
it's going to occur
much sooner than that because what's
going to overtake
the total overturning of the population
pyramid that would
occur naturally is the collapse of the
global economy
that's where we're going to that we're
going to die in a mass extinction not in
a background extinction
it's not like humans are going to die
all alone and all the other animals
continue
no it's not going to happen like that we
we all die in a mass extinction
we you can call it the sixth mass
extinction that's
a lot of people say is already
undergoing right now it's been
happening for maybe thousands of years
lots of the mammals out there are
disappearing
all around us we have very few of them
out there because
very few species and very few numbers
within each species why i mean lions
were i read
150 000 just around 1980s 1990s
today there's only 35 000 of them
they're going away
we don't need lions we're encroaching on
their habitat
they have no place to run their island
is shrinking
so are the uh animals that they eat
you know we we have them just for sport
for entertainment for fun
we go on safari take pictures of them
you know it's fun and the animals are
disappearing all around us why we don't
need those animals
what we need is cows uh sheep
pigs chickens you know the ones we've
domesticated those are the ones we eat
and those have lost a lot of them lost
their genetic diversity as well
so all the mammals right now that are
important that are numerous on the
planet including us
we're on the way out all together okay
and for sure if the economy collapses
we're going to accelerate that process
it's not going to be an overturning of
the population pyramid it's going to be
an overturning of the ecological pyramid
okay uh talking about neanderthals
here's a fellow says problem is you have
we you have as little proof they didn't
exist they didn't as anyone has they did
you weren't there and neither were they
well he was talking about i think the
denisovans and the neanderthals that we
have very little information about them
so
there's a lot of stuff we cannot uh talk
about or that we're speculating
on because uh we were never there you
know 40 000 years 50 000 years ago
people today who can do a study you know
they can't go back in time unless they
believe in general relativity
and uh so we we have no idea
not that we don't have any idea but we
we speculate a lot of what could have
happened to these animals whether we
mated with them i think that's what he
was talking about whether we made it
with the denisovans or whether the
neanderthals mated with them
whether it was in interbreeding whether
it was admixture that's the issue
and yeah the way this works is
you get very few pieces of
evidence okay and this is much worse
than for a
murder trial you know murder trial
typically detectives have a lot more
information than what we have
uh of denisovans and neanderthals we
have very very little information
and so all we can do is take all these
pieces and try to
imagine what could have happened and
there are different theories
and you know some you subscribe to and
you use those as a foundation for a new
theory
we call those assumptions okay and uh
all i can tell you is what you know the
way i look at all this stuff
okay and here's uh evidence proof this
is what
um i uh base
my assumptions on okay
based on this information this uh
evidence that we collected out there
and again evidence uh for a jury trial
is for belief
here we're not talking about belief
we're talking about collecting
evidence only to formulate an assumption
and you might form a different
assumption than me from the same
evidence
and that's fine i can only tell you what
i work with
okay and so this is what i work with
regarding denisovans and i'm saying we
didn't mate
as this fellow is insinuating or
addressing
i don't think we made it with them i
don't think we had admixture i don't
think we had
interbreeding with them because they
were more or less like gorillas
it was a different species altogether
that's my take on this that's the
assumption i make
where do i get this i get it from the
evidence that i find out there
and let me show you what i find okay
these are the teeth that they found from
the nisba four
and eight and again we have only six
pieces of denisovan today we have three
molars one uh splinter
of a bone somewhere they don't even know
what part of the bone
it's from we have a mandible and that's
about it
and um and i just want to compare
the denisova four and eight molar the
same molar with
the neanderthal molar and the
present-day human molar
well you can see that they had very big
teeth
and to the right i show um three
different species completely different
the chimp the australopithecus uh
afarensis
and a human and the afarensis there the
one that i'm interested in there you can
see their
molders were bigger than us ours much
bigger almost twice as big
and if you look at the denisova again
it's
bigger than ours and if anything it
approaches the afarensis
and so the the efferences like i showed
the other day
looked like a monkey okay he'd look
nothing like us and so the question is
whether
what did the denisovan look like did uh
did they look anything like us
would we recognize a denisovan out there
in the
middle of nowhere and i'm saying yes
that we would
we we obviously would recognize a
denisova
because uh if you look at those teeth
you're saying it probably looked more
like afarensis than it
did like a human and i'm sure that a
neanderthal would have
also recognized a denisova
quite easily so i don't think they made
it either i don't think neanderthals
made it with
denisovans where did they get this well
they get this from geneticist
i talked about that the other day the
geneticists have taken over the
neanderthal extinction business
and they did so because they essentially
opened a cottage industry for
geneticists
so now the people who call the shots are
not no longer the paleontologists
you know they start studied morphology
physiology all that stuff that's no good
as far as the geneticists are concerned
they say
we have uh solid evidence and the solid
evidence is we do a gene
genetic study a genome maybe okay
and they look at all the base pairs all
the comparisons there they say well we
have two percent commonality with the
neanderthals
where did we get it we had sex and then
we had the neanderthals and the
denisovans and they have some
commonality where did they get that it
must have been sex
and we have some commonality with
denisovans so where did they get it
where did we get it well we got it also
from sex
and so everything is sex according to
the
geneticists and that's the only theory
they've got
and it created a cottage industry for
them they have job security
and the people who lost control of that
are the people who study paleontology
like neanderthal paleontology
those people have lost completely
because
they have no say in the matter anymore
if they want to know
how the neanderthals disappeared how the
denisovans disappeared
uh they have to go to the geneticist and
the genesis will tell them they say hey
you know it was all these genes we had
sex with them
and they were a smaller population that
was diluted into ours and that's it
that's all you hear about from now on
till the end of
human uh existence and so yeah it's been
taken over
neanderthal business has been taken over
by the geneticist
they tell you how many diseases we
inherited from them
how many we gave to them and if you want
to know how much dna
you share with a neanderthals go get
your dna
or genome or whatever analyze and
they'll tell you they'll say oh
your mother was a neanderthal
that's where we stand today so don't
expect anything different from now on
it's going to be
admixture intermarriage that's what
happened that's how they disappeared
that's it and
it's not going to get any better than
that because again the geneticists have
taken over
and boy that's ballooned that's balloon
every geneticist now is in the
neanderthal business
okay i suggest that people uh tell
me if they're they want to write
something common whatever
start by telling me how animals in the
past became extinct
okay before you tell me how humans
will become extinct in the future okay
if you don't know anything about
extinction you much less can you tell me
anything about
human extinction show me you're an
expert at
extinction and then we'll know that
you can have a theory about
the extinction of humans and the
homework question again
i'll put it over here and that's that uh
you gotta tell me
uh if you can right why the animals on
land disappeared at the same time
more or less right as the animals
indices
okay i hope that's
clear there let's get on with
physics and what are we going to do with
physics well
we're going to um
today we're going to deal with magnetic
lines of force
what are magnetic lines of force
well we say uh well if you sprinkle iron
filings over a magnet then you'll
visualize c observe i don't know what
the word is
uh lines of force but what are they i
mean why do
iron filings align along lines of force
are they real are they physical are they
um
imaginary what are those lines of force
well so let's look at a picture here
okay
this is the subject matter today
magnetic lines of force
okay and i took the magnets out of there
just so that it doesn't get in
in our way and it doesn't distract us
okay can you have a magnetic field
can you have magnetic field lines
without magnets
okay think about that question first
okay
can you have a standalone magnetic field
no magnet no uh no nothing
no iron filings nothing can you have a
magnetic field just standing out there
well if you say that it you can
then you should be able to draw it and
say well what does it look like
okay and you can see that uh
the so-called magnetic field is made of
lines each line is
individual so uh
we're talking about meteorology here
we're talking about
many lines forming a thing
which you call magnetic field well then
the magnetic field is not an object we
got to look at each one of those lines
if you say that those lines are
standalone
what are those lines i i need to be able
to have one
of those lines alone for it to be an
object to be a valid object in physics
okay the field cannot be an object
because first of all field is
just a mathematical uh
concept it means a value at each point
in space
that's not a physical object and if you
say that
magnetic field is made out of these
lines and that the magnetic field is
real because it moves things around
like iron filings and the lines move
things around well you we shouldn't we
can't talk about the magnetic field we
have to talk about what constitutes
the magnetic field and for that we have
to go to the line
and we're not going to talk about a
gazillions of lines we're going to talk
about one
line what is that line if it's real
and if you say well it's real but it
ain't it's imaginary no no
it's black or white it's either real or
unreal it can't be both
okay so uh please tell me if a single
line is real that's what we want to
understand okay and
this is the party line oh by the way uh
there you see if you sprinkle iron
filings well yeah you can see
certain uh patterns and the pattern that
you see on the
bottom left is uh with two wires
conducting turn in the same direction
the wires attract each other okay
and because they uh attract each other
you know it forms that pattern with iron
filing sprinkled around them and the
question is why do they
why do they align in that way and not
when the two wires are conducting
electricity
in opposite direction which by the way
creates a repulsion between the two
wires and why do iron finally sprinkled
over them
form that pattern which you can see is
totally different than the one on the
left
okay so that's the million dollar
question for you today
you got to try to answer that question
why how
what what is the mechanism that mother
nature uses to do this because you can
do this at home
if you have two live wires okay you
point them in the same direction
you turn the electricity on so now
they're live right
they're in the same direction you
sprinkle iron filings you'll see that
the iron filings
will form that pattern okay now you
turn the electricity off for two seconds
you turn one of the wires around
okay you turn the electricity on on both
of them again
and now you get that other pattern
how did mother nature do this this uh
this magic trick because you can't see
anything
and the only way you can see it is by
sprinkling sprinkling iron
iron filings over the wires but there's
a real effect because iron filings are
something you can touch and see
and mother nature is using something
which is invisible
intangible such as lines of force
magnetic field whatever you want to call
it i don't care
and it's that thing is having an effect
on something that's real that can you
can touch that you can see
so is he using um spirits
are you gonna do this with black magic
or are you gonna say no
there's something real in there that
i can't see or touch but is coming in
physical
contact with the skin of each iron
file that should be your conclusion if
you're a rational individual
you're an irrational individual you're
going to do it with black magic spirits
or who knows with what
okay anyways here it is um this is the
party line today this is what uh
the great minds of mathematical physics
have come up with to explain what those
field lines are
and if you read through a couple of them
you'll find the word imaginary in
almost every one of them a field line is
a graphical
visual aid that's what wikipedia says
a vector field defines a direction
magnitude that's it so they're talking
about math
uh what does quarrel say well one of the
files out there says
magnetic field lines inside the magnetic
field are the
what imaginary lines blah blah blah blah
blah
another uh site brilliant magnetic field
lines are
a visual tool another one hyperphysics
says the magnetic field lines can be
thought of as a map
representing the magnetic influence
another one topper answers magnetic
field lines are imaginary lines
and the last one there magnetic field
lines are or
lines of force are the imaginary lines
blah blah blah they're
just going to use it to visualize so all
these people
party line right is that uh all these
lines are just
imaginary they're not real we just put
them in there to draw that's it just to
make sure that you know you can
visualize something but they're saying
the lines themselves
are not there
that's what they're saying and yet they
say that
these lines move iron filings or compel
iron line filings to line up along the
lines
so there's some spirit in there some
abstraction
that is compelling things that you can
see and touch
to align in a certain way
is there nothing there is that what
we're going to conclude
just because what we can't see or touch
it
you see where the problem is okay it's
just an issue of see and touch
we can't see it so it's not there it
doesn't exist
yeah if if that were the definition of
object and of exist yeah
i'm for unfortunately for those who
propose those
theories okay those explanations
um that's those are not the definition
of the word object
or the word exist object is that which
has shape
doesn't mean you can see or touch it and
exist means that
in in addition that object has location
now we have those definitions now we can
make sense
of these iron filings and why they align
like that
okay um i like one fellow
in quora he answered the following uh
yeah there were several there and this
guy said something along
the lines of everybody else after
imaginary et cetera et cetera
but i like something else that he
answered or that he's
stated okay and this is important okay
and this is what he spell says is that
we do not know whether it's theoretic
it's theoretical entities correspond to
ontologically
real entities or are merely imaginative
constructs that have pragmatic utility
within a restricted domain
this applies generally to all physical
entities
posited by theories i don't know what
theories this fellow is talking about i
guess mathematics is that what he's
talking about
but i like that last sentence in other
words physical realism
is philosophy not physics
it's philosophy he says not physics this
is what they're praying this fails
supposedly in mathematical physics
and involves an imaginative imaginative
leap from empirical claims into
non-empirical claims
this file says that because we cannot go
to the lab
and see or touch these things then it's
philosophy
he dismisses it as philosophy he says
that's not physics
physics is what physicist math equations
that's
that's physics as far as this is what
they're they're
taught by wrote in college and it's what
they
repeat out there so he says don't worry
about what's in there because we can't
make sense out of that but it's not
important anyways because
if you can make sense of that you're
doing philosophy anyways
so you know i i always ask um you know
you don't see
gravity you don't see uh you know here
my famous experiment
you let go of the pen pencil pen uh
and it falls to the floor always
downwards never falls upwards i'll
do it again repeatable for it to be
scientific okay so we got to do at least
twice okay
and uh then we have to ask a china man
on the other side of the planet
to do the same thing to do it there so
he repeats my experiment
to make sure that we covered all the
bases so we have a repeatable experiment
we let go of the pen
it falls to the ground is there
something below
the pen is there something above the pen
can you see anything or touch anything
other than air the answer is no
so they say that in order to answer the
question of why this falls to the floor
it's got nothing to do with physics
that's what this fellow is saying
says that's got to do strictly or solely
with
philosophy that's a philosophical
question
so why a magnet attracts another is a
philosophical question what is
electricity
why does it turn on your light that's a
philosophical question how does an atom
work
well we don't know what an atom looks
like so we don't know how it really
works
uh those are philosophical questions and
so on everything they dismiss
as philosophy and so the first question
that you should ask them is why did they
in from the start try to answer those
questions
i mean if they just do math and put
equations fine
stop there keep it in math don't call it
physics
but what they do is they call it physics
and i'll tell you why because
if they just do math and it has nothing
to do if they cannot explain the real
world out there
then their math is totally worthless
it's garbage
they only have an equation which
describes but they can't tell me how the
universe works
and so their math is worthless because
it has no utility in physics
we have no way of answering any question
in physics
so what they've done is since they can't
answer any question in physic they
dismiss that as
philosophy they say oh that's philosophy
so i ask you i mean uh do you think this
is a question of physics
what causes or why the mechanism right
this pen falls to the floor is that a
question of physics what do you think
i think it's just a question philosophy
i thought philosophy was something else
okay so where do we go from here well we
have a
present day individual his name is matt
that's uh one of the ones that i
researched out there and this fella
says that he can explain the how
the why why he tried i don't know
because if he's a mathematical physicist
he should stick to equations to
quantities to measurement to
you know that kind of stuff why does he
cross the line into physics or genuine
physics
and try to give you an explanation of
how it works
how magnetism works in this case okay
and this is him okay a little caricature
of him okay
we're not allowed to put their faces
anymore in youtube that's why i have to
use caricatures
understanding magnetic fields is of
fundamental importance to
astrophysicists
great it's important
so uh is it philosophy or
phys he's saying it's uh to astro what
physicist okay so good
and uh he says let's review how
magnetism works
is he talking about an equation no he's
talking about
he's gonna explain you're to try to
explain to you how
magnetism works did i understand
correctly or am i
off the mark magnetic field lines
what do they do okay
so it seems like mr o'dowd is going to
try to explain
magnetism how it works by how i
i hope he's not going to explain not
explain
describe that it picks up iron filings
at such and such
rate with such and such force or at such
and such
distance and that he's going to do some
measurement that's not the how we're
looking for we're looking for the how
mechanism you know it's like again if
you
pull out a rope that's tied around a
pulley pulling a box upwards
you say well how did you pull the box up
well you don't want the person to answer
saying well the box weighs 10 pounds and
the
rope has so much tensile strength and i
had to pull it with so much force and
invested so much energy
no no we don't want any of that we want
to know how you pull the box
up and for that it's very simple you say
well you know i tied a rope around the
pulley and
i pulled on the rope and that's how the
box went up that's an explanation of
physics
of how the box went up we don't need to
know force we don't need to know energy
we don't need to know mass
we just want to know how you pull the
box to the second floor
okay your boss wants to ask you how did
you pull the box to the second floor i
said well i used a pulley and a rope
i pulled on the rope that was tied
around the pulley that's how the box
went up
that's a explanation of physics these
folks are saying that's philosophy
but now mr o'dowd says he's going to try
to
explain it and i'm not sure what he's
going to explain but let's
i'm i'm going to hold my breath
okay that's by now and so he starts by
saying the phone he says
imagine you can see gravitational fields
oh my god yeah if you can see
gravitational fields you're more
powerful than god because a field is a
concept
and we don't usually see concepts you
know
we can't see intelligence we can't see
love and certainly we cannot see a field
and a field is a
concept mathematical concept what is a
field
many values uh or many points in space
meaning
many values around in a in space around
a certain object
and that's not a physical object that's
a that's a concept and we cannot see
concepts
but he says uh it would mean seeing the
literal threads of the fabric of
space-time
now he's getting more into my world he's
saying that there are threads
okay some some tangible thing out there
i guess or
at least something that has shape right
he says threads
threads tug lightly towards the earth
tightly towards uh the sun lightly
towards the earth tightly towards the
sun
yeah looks like he's saying that the sun
and the earth are somehow connected
physically and he says think of
electrons as being connected to
all other points in the universe by
invisible strands
now looks like he's describing the rope
model okay so i guess he's on the right
track
but the problem is that he says you got
to think of it you got to make believe
you got to
imagine it as if
so where in the quantum model do we find
these strands these threads
do you see them anywhere do you see them
in the standard model
i mean they talk about and they say you
have to make believe
as if why don't they make them real why
don't they say well they are there
because they're saying as if well
if if it's as if that means that that
way you can explain
but if you're going to use just
particles discrete particles that are
not
connected at all to each other then yeah
you're going to have problems explaining
in fact you're going to have to
be doing a little bit of magic to be
able to find out how one particle
interacts with another one
without anything in between that's the
issue
and so quantum which is a discrete
particle theory cannot explain
how a particle pushes or pulls on
another one unless
push only through contact but if they're
separated you can't either push or pull
so you cannot explain mother nature's
universe with discrete particles meaning
that they are isolated from other
particles by whatever
we'll call it space vacuum which they
say is made of particles as well so
i don't know they always fill in the
holes with something because otherwise
they can't and they cannot explain
pull with that they can only explain
push
okay he continues and he's gonna
try to explain i guess this says
magnetism is
generated when electrically charged
particles move
so he's going to say they move okay so
they move and how does that generate
uh you know how do they how does
he generate magnetism just because a
so-called charge was a
really a concept mathematical concept
1.6 times 10 to the minus 19 coulombs
that's what
charge means just the value
and they're saying this value moves you
have this 10 to the minus 19 whatever
moving right you know when numbers begin
to move it's you know you have too much
to drink
okay so these numbers are moving
let's concede how does that generate a
magnetic field
he just states that insinuating that
it's a particle what's a particle a zero
dimensional concept meaning it's a value
that's all a particle is in quantum so
we have a
charged number this number moves and
somehow it creates a
magnetic field or magnetism
so what are they talking about what's
the physical interpretation of this
what are we staring at charged particles
tend to spiral around
a magnetic field lines and here's uh
more or less what he's
talking about okay this is this is their
notion okay
magnetic field lines form in concentric
circles around moving charges
okay you can see how the charge is going
around and around and they
follow i guess these arrows which are
supposed to represent
the magnetic field lines and the
question is how does that particle which
again is
you can see it's got all these locations
okay so that means that
this this particle is a discrete
particle it's moving around why is it
moving around in circles
what's coming in contact with a particle
for it to do that
magic that's what we want to understand
i mean
so far he's got magic he's he's using a
magic wand and saying
the particle goes round and round and
round yeah tell me why
don't tell me that does tell me how it
does so
okay maybe he does it at the next step
perhaps let me remove this for a second
here
so maybe we just gotta wait and uh for
him to finish his uh
presentation and so here's his finishing
touch
okay this is where i guess he explains
it he said there's only one universal
magnetic field
some of the field lines connect to this
greater magnetic field of the solar
system
and even to the galaxy so i hope you
understand and can explain to your son
today or your daughter
um how magnets how magnetism works
that's it that's that's all you'll find
so
so he hasn't explained anything he
hasn't explained why the charge
goes around and around the magnetic
field
lines he hasn't told us what the
magnetic field lines are
we know that charge particle is just a
number
so even if we can see that it's a little
ball a little particle
we still don't understand how that
little ball goes around the field lines
why it goes in a spiral we have no idea
it just
is so this
this is just someone measuring something
out there that he doesn't see
or touch he comes up with this notion
and all he's got is a description all
he's done is a measurement comes up with
a description
and collects his nobel prize he hasn't
explained anything
right okay uh we can go back in time
and find out that there was
a gentleman his name was michael faraday
little mikey
mickey and um he also
said that he was probably the first one
to propose that
all these uh entities things atoms
okay things uh
are interconnected he already had this
notion that through
from from doing experiments in the lab
he couldn't see or touch him but he
was convinced intuitively convinced that
they were all
interconnected okay somehow
he could not explain it but he says i'm
convinced that these are all
interconnected so he came up with
interconnection
but let's hear the whole story this is
this is where it stands okay
he says maybe ask what lines of force
are there in nature
which are fitted to convey such an
action and supply
for the vibrating theory the place of
the ether
i do not pretend to answer the question
with any confidence all i can say is
that i do not perceive in
any part of space whether vacant or
filled with matter
anything but forces and lines in which
they are
exerted okay forces obviously
is an abstraction but lines hopefully he
was thinking of something a little more
solid
but here's where he starts getting very
deep into this he says
w which i am so bold to put forth
considers
therefore radiation is a kind of species
of vibration
in the lines of force which are known to
connect
particles and also masses of matter
together he almost came up with a rope
model
given a few more years of life he
probably would have figured it out maybe
i don't know
but of course he was influenced by a lot
of mathematicians
and he was excessively respective
respect respecting
all the so-called eminences of those
days
and so he kind of uh searched from
giving us solid answer and
he says the ether lies between the
particles and so carries on the
vibrations willst
it is by the lines of force between the
centers of the particles that the
vibration is continued
okay he said this uh really towards the
end of his life
1846 he was a you know i think he died
in the 1860s
and so he was already uh imagining that
there's something physical there
he already said it in 1852 there i
cannot conceive curtain lines of force
without the conditions of a physical
existence in that intermediate space
so he was on the right track he
he intuitively thought that all these
masses
meaning atoms were somehow connected
because this one over here affected that
one over there
he came up already in those days with
the notion of entanglement
okay and here he will follow up on that
he says the following
okay this is all from a letter
essentially a letter that you wrote to a
friend okay it says for all the powers
of matter of gravitation is the one in
which the force extends
to the greatest possible distance from
the supposed nucleus
okay being infinite in relation to the
size of the ladder
and reducing the nucleus to a mere
center of force
so we have this nucleus think of it as
an atom that's
the best way you could imagine it
remember they were thinking of the
daltonian
uh atom it was just a little ball that's
all i imagine
and he's saying you know that's the
nucleus and it's got all these
ramifications that converge upon that
so-called atom
okay the smallest atom of matter on the
earth
acts directly on the smallest atom of
matter
in the sun how does it do that
and he's suggesting that there is some
connection there some
physical connection he's insinuating
this okay intuitively
atom which to our knowledge are at at
least 19
times that distance and indeed in
cometary masses
far more are in a similar way tied
together
by the lines of force extending from and
belonging to
each so he's talking about lines of
force he doesn't know what they are but
he's saying they're connected by these
so-called lines of force
which he said a minute ago he says
there's something physical in that space
okay what is there in the condition of
the particles of the supposed ether
okay if there be even only one such
particle between
us and the sun that can in
acceptability and extent compared to
this
so he already had this notion that
uh somehow these atoms from the sun
to the earth to you were connected
but he couldn't make sense of it because
again what he couldn't see
or touch whatever was there he went
he did a lot of experience he couldn't
see or touch him he said well there's
nothing there but i know there's
something there
that's more or less where he stood on
that and uh
here's his notion of entanglement okay
he
he really is the first guy to come up
with it okay he says
i inclined to believe that when there
are intervening particles of matter
being themselves only centers a force
they take part in carrying out carrying
on the force through the line but that
when there are none
the line proceeds through space okay so
he's saying there's something
going through that space it's a line
that's the best way he could describe it
okay
for supposed two bodies a and b distant
from each other
and under mutual action and therefore
connected by lines of force
if one of the bodies move in the least
degree
right or left or if its power be shifted
for a moment within the mass
then an effect equivalent to a lateral
disturbance
will take place in the resultant in the
resultant upon which we are fixing our
attention
okay so you're saying this one over here
affects that one over there
entanglement right there you have it
okay so he already came up with that
idea
okay four either it will increase in
force
whilst the neighboring results are
diminishing or it will fall in force as
they are
increasing the occurrence of a change at
one
end of a line of force easily suggests a
consequent change
at the other so he's treating all these
lines of force that connect masses
as real entities okay
and uh so yeah i think uh you can
say that mr uh faraday discovered
entanglement or proposed entanglement
except
except that towards the end he chickened
out
okay he chickened out he had no huevos
okay and so he denied everything he said
in that same paper in that same letter
he says the following okay
which is unfortunate really
[Music]
give me a second here
not true i can't see it
okay anyways uh what he said at the end
uh i can't show it i don't know why it's
not coming up
um but he said at the end he's saying oh
by the way i shouldn't have said all
that
because it was just speculation and i
should have
really discussed it with other people
and get their approval before saying all
that okay that's what he said at the end
maybe i'll show it next time but it's
unfortunate that he
backtracked and at the end of that
letter at the end of you could say that
paper
he said you know all this it looks like
they're all interconnected but i take
all that back because i should have
really consulted with other people
before saying all that
that's how he ended his uh letter that's
really unfortunate
and maybe i'll show it next time okay
anyways
uh so where does this take us well first
of all
maxwell said essentially the same thing
okay so he had the same idea
says field the space in the neighborhood
of the electric and
magnetic bodies that's how you define
field in that space there is what
matter in motion okay so he said that
uh 13 years after mr faraday
wrote his letter okay and he said that
shortly before he died also he died
relatively young
okay um what do we propose well we
propose exactly what
these two gentlemen suggested we propose
that
all atoms are interconnected we propose
an interconnected universe
just like mr o'dowd suggested insinuated
he didn't suggest it he says
you have to make believe or uh
imagine it as if okay but he never
defined what that
line what those lines are those
interconnecting lines are
neither than mr faraday neither the mr
maxwell
we're saying there are those lines in
there the only thing we have to do all
these years is
redefine the word object it's not that
which you can see your touch
it's that which has shape you can't see
or touch
every object that has shaped
every shape out there okay and so this
is what we're proposing we're saying
that
whether on the one hand we have
mathematical physics
they propose discrete particles which
are not connected in any way
and we wonder how those particles
interact either pushing or pulling
if they are not in contact with each
other the only way we can make sense of
it is under the rope model and that is
interconnectivity okay so those are the
two options i don't think there's a
third option
and what we're proposing is inter
connectivity
okay so uh we think it's a powerful
idea we're doing the same thing as
faraday suggested as maxwell suggested
as mr o'dowd suggests even to today that
everything is interconnected
we're not going to say as if we're not
going to say that
you have to imagine it as if we're
saying they are
in fact interconnected and an object is
not that which you can see or touch it's
that which has shape
and yeah these uh interconnections have
shape but you cannot see or touch them
that's the only assumptions we had to
make all these years
okay um so here's um
how we see these lines of force we're
saying that all these
lines of force are actual threads
and those threads come out of the atoms
uh the
electron shells that encapsulate the
proton stars
i've shown that in the past i'm not
going to go into a little detail here
but
we're saying that these threads are
coming from the ropes and from the
electron shells that
are bound to
other electron shells forming these long
what we call serpentines
when they move around at great speeds
they
move these threads around as well
and the
accumulation of all these threads is
what forms that so-called
magnetic field okay that's what we
measure out there and we measure it web
because we can see the iron filings that
are affected by these
threads these threads move through the
iron filings
okay they move them and what they do is
they by doing so they
also magnetize the iron filings
so these are moving right through them
okay
okay so let's move on here
and here we see uh the mechanism of
attraction
and repulsion we can now superimpose
um these motions on top of the
patterns we saw earlier with the iron
filings thrown
over two wires first that
conduct turn in the same direction and
on the one on the right you'll see them
in opposite directions
and what else what i'm trying to show
here is that you can see that the
patterns
that are formed are that between the two
wires
you'll see that these iron families
line up with circles then slightly
out a little short a little distance
outwards you'll see that they form this
figure eight
and finally the iron filings it's like
if they circle
both wires and what is happening is that
again the
threads are moving around when the
threads move between the two wires they
move as
circles at some point farther out
you'll find out that the thread is as if
the thread
comes in and it gets uh pulled by the
other thread
in the figure eight direction right at
the bottom you see that
and then the threads that are farther
out they just circle both
wires that's what we're saying is
happening and that's why the iron fans
align
along the so-called lines of force which
are
actually the sweeping of threads and
that's what the lines of force
are and in the case of uh repulsion
you know here you have one of the
iron one of the wires it's swinging the
threads
clockwise the other one is swinging them
counterclockwise
so they meet between the two wires
and they push each other away they they
kind of squash there in the
in between and that's exactly the
pattern that you see when you sprinkle
iron filings over them
so we can justify the why the iron
valleys align
along those um patterns
because it's the threads that are moving
through them
okay and they force they those threads
have an effect on the iron phalanx
on the atoms that form the iron filings
that's essentially
what we're saying here okay and we see
this uh when we look at
the mechanism of attraction and
repulsion i
like to show it also always with my two
fellows
axel and rod okay here we have actual
rod and we can see what's happening uh
they both swing counterclockwise they're
ropes
and when they you bring the magnets
together what they're doing is
attracting each other
okay and remember the one on the bottom
is moving
opposite to the ones on the top so if
the tops are moving
counterclockwise the ones on the bottom
move clockwise
now if you turn it around now we're
gonna have repulsion south against south
and what you see is again the the
threads we're gonna are going to be
clashing against each other both on the
top and then the bottom
okay so that's the mechanism of
attraction we can explain not only why
the iron filings
align along those patterns but also
why two magnets attract and repel
because
of the swinging of threads okay
and here one more time is the repulsion
okay
south against south the threads are
going in opposite direction
the closer you get them to each other uh
the
more resistance there's going to be
because why
you have more threads more
the atoms are closer to each other from
one magnet than the other
and so there are more threads
intervening so it's harder to push two
magnets like south against south
together you know you got more you've
got a whole bunch of
gazillions of threads pushing against
each other as they swing around
okay okay so that gives you an idea what
the
uh what what the threads are what the
lines of force are they're the threads
that are swinging
around okay and um
you might say well is that the case well
here's a little evidence
again this has nothing to do with
convincing it's just again an assumption
and you can take that as an assumption
because you should be able to explain to
your little kid
how magnus attract and repel whether you
agree with it or not but at least you
can explain the mechanism
with these threads okay and here you see
something that
a lot of people don't know about and
that is that if you put a magnet under
water
the iron filings are picked up like one
at a time
okay so that means that something is
moving
in that region we call uh
lines of force and those lines of force
are what we're saying is swinging
threads
that's why they pick up one of these at
a time
otherwise you know you wouldn't be
lifting one at a time like you see there
something is in motion in that region
that's why they're being pulled one at a
time
okay and i'm saying that uh the at least
the
threads give us an idea of
how magnetism could be working and
how it attracts iron filings in this
case underwater one at a time
okay let's go to the conclusions okay on
magnetic lines of force
what what can we conclude from this
well here we have it okay we have um
from mikey faraday to matt batty
o'dowd no one has ever explained
the physical mechanism of how magnet
attracts and repels
so you have all these people on youtube
especially and they say oh let me
explain to you how magnets work
not one of them explains how magnets
work in other words what the mechanism
of attraction
is what they're going to do is describe
and there's one i think uh
either berkeley or stanford university
and what the fellow says
is that the electrons of this magnet
spin
and the electrons of this magnet spins
and because they spin
one magnet attracts another see they
never explain it's like you're saying
well this top spins over here this top
spins over there
and because they they spin one attracts
the other
well you still haven't explained how how
one spinning thing
attracts another spinning thing if
they're both discrete
entities so again they haven't explained
it
you need to explain the mechanism and
that's when they say well that's
philosophy
so why did you try to explain it in the
first place why do you say that you know
when you don't know
squat yeah that's the problem and
quantum mechanics has no
physical interpretation because no
mathematician has identified
the invisible intangible mediators what
the lines of force
they say those are abstractions those
are
imaginary you're not supposed to take
them as real entities
and then what makes up a field well all
these lines are force
meteorology what is a field many lines
of force okay so we don't care about the
field what is the line of force is it
real or not can it move
an iron filing can that interact with an
iron filing or not
and the iron family is that thing that
you can see or touch
so you have something invisible which
you cannot see or touch
that's affecting something that's
visible that's you can see your touch
is is that uh invisible intangible thing
a non-entity doesn't it exist doesn't it
have
form how does it affect something that
you can see here
and touch it's like saying you know the
ghost
move the curtain okay what does a ghost
look like
oh no it's not a real entity well how
did it
affect the curtain which is a real
entity which i can touch and see
and you're saying there's something out
there
that touches and and sees or touches the
the curtain moves it but then you tell
me there's nothing there that that thing
that goes that spirit
is a non-entity simply because you can't
see your touch
and you can't draw it you can't draw it
because why
uh well because you've never seen a
ghost but that's what you're
explaining how the curtain moved
that's the same thing here okay
mathematician dismissed elucidating the
invisible intentional mediators as
philosophy
so why do they continuously attempt to
do philosophy
trying to explain right mechanisms if it
has nothing to do with mathematical
physics which is what
descriptions an equation is only a
description
okay to visualize and understand the
mechanism of magnetism proposed by the
rope
hypothesis we need only to make the
media
mediators visible
draw it show me a picture show me the
movie
okay so on with uh the questions the
that people asked since last time got a
couple of them here
first of all it says uh again
says weight is derived by putting mass
on a scale and measuring the weight is
not
the mass uh no we don't put masses
on scales okay there's no such monster
as mass
you can put a cube you can put a rock
you can put a tree
on a scale you cannot put a
quotation mass no such monster as a
mass mass is a concept okay yeah and it
is a synonym
exact perfect synonym of the word weight
there's no difference whatsoever
between weight and mass you heard it
here for the first time let me repeat
that
in case you said well maybe you heard
wrong mass and weight are synonyms
there's no difference between them
because
no one in the last 10 000 years has been
able to define
mass and weight in such a way as to
distinguish them
that's the issue okay and so the weight
is not the mass
yes it is the mass and here um
let's go step by step here the first
thing we want to make sure is that
in in science we don't uh center
information transfer energy or what put
mass
on a scale we don't stretch the force we
don't wave the way we don't accelerate a
charge
we don't bend time we don't warp a field
okay
we can't use words of physics to
apply them to concepts to mathematical
concepts
what all these people have done is reify
can criticize i guess you could say it
all these concepts they've turned these
concepts into physical
objects okay that's what they've done
okay and uh just in case the cell says
the weight is not the mass let's find
out what mass
is let's look up the definitions find
out if we know what we're talking about
okay and if you look at the wikipedia
says mass is not the same as weight
okay so it agrees with this fellow but
it says even though mass is determined
by measuring that uh the object's weight
okay so what do we mean then what is the
difference how come mass is not the same
as weight
and then they say in physical science
meaning mathematical
physics okay mathematics one may
distinguish conceptually between at
least
seven different aspects of mass or seven
physical notions that involve the
concept mass
in other words uh they use ad hoc
definitions they say oh for this one
we're going to use this one
and for that other one well we'll use
this other one that's how they
handle it in so-called mathematical
physics they move the goal posts on you
that's what they're doing okay uh
so we have to go beyond wikipedia
because you know those are written by
who knows who
so let's go with the big guys okay the
people who have
big degrees and big names okay so we
can't
question authority here okay here it is
yeah here we have john wheeler mr edwin
taylor
what do they say in their book
space-time physics they say
nature does not offer us any concept as
the amount of
matter mass is not
the quantity of matter or the measure of
a quantity of matter or
anything related to the amount of matter
history has struck down every proposal
to define such
a term they have no definition for the
word mass
even if we could count number of atoms
or by any other counting method try to
evaluate
evaluate amount of matter that number
would not equal mass
now what part did you not understand
that we don't have a definition
of the word mass today and um
you know since the
really the 16th century people think it
was
what is it a galileo who did the
trick of throwing two stones or two
weights
from the tower pisa uh and that's how he
proved or
confirmed or whatever that two
masses of different weights fall at the
same time
now the fellow was almost almost 50
years earlier did that trick and it
wasn't galileo in fact galileo probably
never did that trick
and i'll tell you why because his boss
the guy he replaced
at the university of padua
he had already written a book about that
apparently molety did the trick
of going to the tower piece and dropping
two ways but even he wasn't the first
guy the first guy was stevens
simon stevens so keep this in mind
because all the phds get this wrong
not one of them gets it right okay they
don't do any research they just repeat
by rote
and so here it is uh this is the guy who
really came up with that
okay the experience against aristotle
meaning you know that
one weight would fall uh faster than
another weight
says is the following let us take uh
so and so right did and myself have done
two spheres of lead the one
ten times larger and heavier than the
other and drop them together from a
height of 30 feet
onto a board or something on which they
give a perceptible sound
then it will be found that the lighter
will not be 10 times longer on its way
than the heavier but that they fall
together onto the board
so simultaneously that their two sounds
seem to be
one in the same wrap he said this
in uh what was it 1586.
okay remember uh galileo had just uh
a couple years earlier just taken over
uh the
university of padua as a mathematics
professor
so uh simon steven was the guy who did
it i don't know if anyone did it before
him
i i looked it up and uh so far i haven't
found anyone before steven he
his work is on the line you can find it
out there okay
so uh yeah he's the first guy who
doesn't he showed that
two objects that have different weights
fall at the same time does that mean
that we have two different masses
well yeah because they weigh differently
and you say well if you take uh
i don't know a rock that you weigh here
on earth okay
and you take it to the moon it weighs
less
and you add usually well but their mass
the mass has not changed
but yes it has changed it changed
because
the way we determine mass is by weighing
we wait here on earth we wait on the
moon so there's no difference
the mass has changed show me that the
mass has not changed
and hopefully you don't use the term
quantity of matter
because mr wheeler has told you that
that's not mass
so please define the word mass first
then tell me that mass and weight are
different
and i wish you good luck because i'm
gonna tear your definition to pieces
okay so don't bring nonsense you better
study for a whole year the word
mass before you come here and uh just
show your
ignorance okay we treat ignorant
people with the respect that they
deserve
okay so don't just come off the top of
your head and say oh this is what i
learned in high school yeah
i'm good sorry okay phil says the square
has no location
no kidding yeah correct so let's first
define what location is we say distance
separation between
objects okay so you have separation gap
we call that distance okay and then
location is the set of distance from
this object to all the others in the
universe
or the group that you're considering
right
so we we have a definition for uh
the word uh location okay we
keep that in mind well let me keep that
up there okay
and so what's the question with the
square well here we have
the issue there let me get there
object that which i shape okay a square
has shape
so a square qualifies as an object
according to that definition
okay so far so good okay a figure
this is from euclid's element he says
more or less the same thing
is that which is contained by any
boundary or boundaries
okay so he more or less was on the right
foot the only problem with euclid's
definition is that he never used it
more important than that he never
realized how important that definition
was
and then the other issue is that he
defined boundary
in definition 15 as saying well what is
a boundary then
well boundary is uh the end of a figure
the perimeter of a figure so he's got a
circular set of definitions
figure is that which contained by
boundary and a boundary is that which
um is the endpoint of or the
perimeter of a figure great so euclid
had no
idea okay but he at least had the
more or less the idea that it figures
that which has shape
which is how we have the scientific
definition today
okay so we have an object figure
whatever you want to call it substance
thing
okay something uh that which
has shaped does the square have shape
well if you can draw a square on a piece
of paper then
it has shape and you're staring at an
object because
it has shape that's the definition we
have there you don't like it
you got to define the word object before
you use it in a sentence
you can't say well you don't agree we
don't care if you agree or not
give us a definition that is scientific
that you can use consistently
that's where the issue is okay so what
does exist
because here we're talking about whether
a square first is an object and they're
whether it
exists which is separate topic
altogether
uh exists object plus location we define
location as what well here it was
put it over here what was location set
of distances
what is this separation between objects
okay so we got that
so we're saying that a square has shape
but a square does not have location
what has location is the paper in the
ink i hope that's
clear as well okay so we're using these
words consistently
okay we don't care if this destroys your
religion the only way to get around that
is
come and define and don't bring
definitions say ah but that's authority
no no
authority has no place in science you
gotta define such a way that you can use
the definition consistently
rationally scientifically
okay therefore a square is an object
that does not exist
it's an object because it has shape it
doesn't exist because it doesn't have
location
straight forward physics only deals with
objects that exist that have location
okay so we don't deal with squares we
don't deal with cubes ideal cubes
we don't deal with tri bars we don't
deal with superman we don't deal with
snow white okay or any of those ghosts
waves any of those we don't use
concepts we have to do things with
objects what is an object
that which has shape only those that
exist
form part of physics those objects that
don't exist such as squares and so on
they're not part of physics so we don't
care about them because they have no
location okay so that's that's the um
you can use these words consistently now
we don't have to uh
you know be guessing or wondering what
the guy who said
what the guy meant it's straightforward
object that would just shape exist
object plus a location if it doesn't
have location
it doesn't exist and it's not part of
physics we're done
that's how simple it was all these years
okay and then
yeah it relies on definitions and of
course this destroys a lot of
religions or like i like to say the
definition of the word object
destroys all religions and so it's
religious folks which are going to
fight it to the end but there's only one
way to fight and has to define
define it in such a way that you can use
it consistently
don't bring authority or
democracy into the picture don't say
well everybody voted for it
we don't care about democracy we don't
care about authority okay
not in science that's religion okay
thou says uh just because you can
imagine a table in
your mind doesn't make it an object well
you got to define the word object
in order for us to understand you but
then the word table
always refers to an object whether
imagining drawn scene or touch
the word table does it refer to an
object yes or no that's the only issue
and you can't say well you know uh
according to the c touch now you first
you got to define object you got to
define the word you got to defend
your definition of the word object then
you can apply it if you can't defend
your definition of the word object
you're lost already you have no case
we take the microphone away from you
you're not allowed to speak please
define the word object and defend it
defend your definition you can't defend
it you know you get is a religion you
know you they cry baby you know that's
all you can do
okay um well it says
an object is three-dimensional oh is
that what an object is three-dimensional
well uh is that the definition of object
because uh you know i mean what do you
mean by that and it says which can be
seen and touched in some fashion
well the question is whether you can see
or touch the
table that the klingon has on the other
side of the universe
i can't touch it so how can you show me
that that table
is an object if i can't see or touch it
i can't see or touch the one you're
imagining
unless you draw it and when you draw it
uh yeah it has shape
but i can't touch the table i can touch
the paper and the ink
but i can't touch the table
can't test the one you're imagining i
can't that's the one the
klingon has i can't touch the one the
chinese that man has on the other side
of our planet so is that table
an object when i can't see or touch it
you can't see or touch
it so your definition doesn't work
you can't use the c-touch criterion and
you can't
use the three-dimensional one because
again how do you know it's
three-dimensional
the only the only way is to see and
touch it and we can't see or touch it
because it's on the other side of the
planet
so it's very clear you lost you have no
doubt you can't defend your definition
you gotta let go you gotta you know
concede
that you can't defend your definition
you don't have a scientific definition
all you have is
religion because you have something
outside the bounds of
physics and science you cannot defend
your definition that's how simple it is
okay so yeah what can i say all you can
do is
just cry and say well yeah they
destroyed my religion
that's why you don't like it okay uh
continue says uh
we don't just rely on our limited census
for this
well yeah that's the problem see
anything involving census
is subjective we don't know how drugged
you are
we don't know uh if you are out of your
mind
so senses don't enter the picture in
science at all
you don't care about sense of what you
perceived we don't know how
how drunk you were when you perceive
that ghost
okay so census play no role whatsoever
and yeah census it's subjective science
is
objective it's gotta be objective
i explain something objectively and uh i
point to it that's objective
i point to a rock and say rock that's
objective
okay you can't say well imagine you know
no you got a point to it okay i point to
my rope here's my rope
that's that's what i'm talking about
when i say robe electromagnetic robe it
looks something like this
okay so i've got something to point to
what are you going to point to for a
wave a bunch of vectors
what are you going to put to a zero
dimensional particle
with quotation particle zero dimensional
means nothing there
what's a zero d singularity which is the
center of black hole well so far we've
got nothing
so again you can't point to any of the
so-called objects of mathematical
physics
okay so science is objective and yeah we
killed
the observer there are
no observers in science only in
mathematical physics are there
observers because they rely on testimony
and witnesses
science we kill the witness we do it
mafia style
okay we don't like witnesses no
testimonials
no testimonies don't tell me what you
saw draw it
okay draw it draw your zero dimensional
particle
draw your so-called wave draw your
vortex what is that vortex
tornado tornado of what what is
vortexing
yeah you can't draw it you're not doing
physics
we deal with objects okay
next issue says
i lost his uh uh his comment i think he
deleted it or something i can't find it
but
he was saying essentially that uh
this is what i get gather from him that
maybe uh
there's more than one single thread out
there maybe there's two single threads
which are intertwined somehow
and what he does is he takes my single
thread twines it around
to make that rope in number two and then
he tries to build the universe the atoms
and everything else okay
which is number three there and he
suggested the alternative that i guess
there's uh
he says two single loops but i don't
know where where they intersect or
or what i'm not sure what he's drawing
there exactly
all i can do is tell you the following
what i
how i see this okay and this is the way
i see it
you have if you start at one end
of the single thread in the universe and
you just take it all the way well you
end up at your starting point
that's what i'm saying is the single
thread then from here
the construction of atoms start in in
many
threads that intersect but i'm not
saying that you first construct a rope
and then from the rope you try to
construct the atoms which is what i
think this fellow is saying
okay so
you know i think he's misinterpreting
what i'm proposing
you know just like i could be
misinterpreting what he's proposing okay
okay um next issue
fellow says always with the rope says
your
explanation is understandable but you
might add the rope jumpers
just rope jumpers i think he's referring
to the two fellas on
axel and rod skipping ropes i think
that's what he's talking about but i
don't know for sure
says ropes have special subunit
properties that make the
additive effect of one larger rope but
it can
be cut and reassembled uh no not ours
we don't cut the rope rope is uncuttable
you can't cut the rope anymore then you
can cut
molasses think of it as a fluid
okay that uh you can go through it but
you're not really
cutting the the fluid like in we do in
real life today
you know you you can cut atoms separate
atom
momentarily but and you can separate
atoms because everything is made of
atoms
you can't do that with the the rope
essentially the thread
you can't cut across the thread because
if a thread goes through a thread
momentarily at the moment
where the two threads touch or occupy a
single location
they don't cut across they blend to form
so to speak the same molasses the same
honey the same river
okay i showed that the other day so i'm
not sure exactly what this fellow
is referring to all i can ask him is to
clarify in more detail what he's really
suggesting another fella says
uh regarding computer simulations that
you
are not a human being you're really a
computer simulation by some
alien or god or who knows out there okay
mother nature maybe uh here's an
outlandish idea if the universe is a
simulation
events that accelerate an object cause
the future position of that object and
photons this then
destinated to reach it to be
recalculated
and he goes on and on and on
why do people even bother or think about
these
uh uh you know um
simulations simulation is nonsense what
these people are saying that there's
some alien
out there that created us and that we're
just this computer simulation
that's like you know these these people
sometimes watch
too much uh star trek or
you know any of those uh uh
sci-fi uh movies
it's absolute the matrix you know
something like that it's all nonsense
those i mean if you want to include
those for
some movie and maybe you want to write a
script
great i mean i love to watch sci-fi but
you know in hollywood in movies but
don't bring that
at all into science if it has no
possibility whatsoever
but a lot of these people you know they
say oh a simulation maybe we are simula
that should stop it has no chance
whatsoever don't even present it as
saying oh i brainstorm all these ideas
they're nonsensical ideas they have no
place
in science why why even bring
simulations like that when they have no
chance whatsoever
to say well what if you know that's just
nonsense this
stuff for uh for again for people who
want to do
fantasy or you know who have their feet
off the ground
or just want to shoot the bull at the uh
water cooler
or the bar that's fine but don't bring
it into science
has no place whatsoever in design don't
even say what if no
throw it in the garbage can okay there's
no place in science all you're doing is
distracting people from
real science okay trying to explain how
this universe works once we got that we
don't need all this sci-fi stuff
star trek all that goes down to trash
that's only for
again for people in hollywood or novels
or whatever
okay another foul says howdy these
invisible intentions
out of these invisible intangible ropes
that are only an object in your mind as
physical mechanisms
make nature geometry such as the
phytotax fibonacci sequence golden ratio
what is he talking about well he's
talking about all these calculations
that they do out there
in the case of the golden ratio uh if
you take
one plus two gives you three so you put
a three now you take two plus three the
last two numbers
two plus three gives you five okay now
you take 3 plus 5 gives you 8
take 8 plus 5 gives you 13 and so on
down the line
and when you do this and you take that
number that addition
and divided by the last number it gives
you the golden ratio
it approaches this golden ratio the more
numbers you do
which is 1.618 and this fascinates a lot
of these people religious folk you know
mathematicians who
have gone beyond the call of duty and
they're fascinated by these
uh numbers and it just drives them wild
it just blows their mind completely
away because they're i think they're
autistic people in the end anyone who
does
this kind of you know little thing and
harps so much upon it it's got mental
problems
okay but see the question here is how do
these invisible
intangible ropes that are only object in
your mind
make nature geometry
he's not asking for an equation he's not
asking
for a description he wants an
explanation i want to make sure that
people understand that right off the bat
he wants to know how uh some of these uh
produce that you see in nature like
petals of roses and so on how do they
relate in this case to the
invisible intangible ropes he wants a
mechanism
he wants an explanation not a
description
okay so that's what he's asking for it's
like all these mathematicians
they give you an explanation you say
it's irrational it doesn't make any
sense
you cannot even imagine yeah that's
philosophy anyways
then why did you ask for it why did you
try to answer the question
and this one was asking also he wants an
explanation he doesn't want a
description
hopefully we'll give him an explanation
because that's what he wants
so we won't give him an equation we're
not going to give him numbers which is
probably what he's
uh thinking about but he's not going to
get because that's what he's
that's not what he's asking okay so
let's make sure what he's
asking first okay and let's give them an
answer
okay here's the explanation okay
and it's got a little to do with the
rope model because remember
the rope works at the sub atomic level
it's something so thin so small
that compared to an atom it's almost
vanishingly small
and we can't see an atom no what he's
asking here about
you know all these uh fibonacci
sequences the golden ratio all these
things that are related to the
nature because he's asking how does it
make all these natural geometries
like roses uh that you know that twirl
around and so on
okay and so he's asking for an
explanation that goes
not only beyond atomic level but beyond
molecular level you're talking about
something macro
already something you can see and touch
okay and so here you see
the explanation what explanation that's
out there okay this is
one explanation doesn't mean you have to
agree with it but it's a i think
in my opinion pretty good explanation
says if plants want to maximize
the exposure of their leaves to the sun
for example
they really need to grow them at
non-repeating
angles okay the spirals we see in nature
are a
consequence of this behavior nature is
lazy
and wants to do the least amount of work
for the maximum result
the simplest way to do this is by giving
simple instructions like
first grow then turn a certain angle and
grow again
okay so you see these uh trees and
plants and so on uh they they fork out
at different angles
which approximate what this fall said
you know the golden ratio etc
why because they're uh trying to get a
little bit of sun
and so through trial and error after
millions of years they decided that
you know the leaves have to grow at
different angles in order to get that
sun
they can't grow underneath another leaf
in general because then they won't get a
sun
and if they don't get a sun they don't
grow and so on so this is i think a
pretty good explanation from my point of
view
but here's the description okay this is
important because this is what this guy
probably had in mind he thought there
was
he was going to receive a mathematical
answer
and says mathematically this is better
what described
by fractals okay what do fractals do
they describe they don't explain so you
cannot explain why that rose there
has all these petals arranged in a
spiral pattern
by using fractals fractals can only
describe
what you're staring at if you want an
explanation you got to go to the red
part on the top
where it says you know why
these petals go at different angles and
it's to receive more sunlight
that's how they developed over again
millions of years probably
okay so again uh these logarithmic
spirals that's only a description
it doesn't explain anything okay
and the rope again i'm not sure
you you can relate it to the rope at all
because it's like saying well
how does light do it well the only thing
you can say is photosynthesis
that's the only intervention and the
rope
simply says that every atom in the sun
is connected
to every atom that forms a leaf
okay and it just gives it what is called
the
photosynthesis meaning you know it's
receiving these
uh rays from the sun in other words
these signals
that stimulate that atom multiply that
times gazillions and you know what's
happening to a leaf
but that doesn't have anything to do
with this question the question that
he's asking is why do they
the petals form different angles that
correspond to these descriptions
mathematical descriptions
and for that you need physics not math
and physics is
hey you know leaves evolved in such a
way that
they're not at the same you know one on
top of the other because if they were
like that
the second one on the bottom would not
receive the sun would not develop those
died the ones that
continued living were the ones that were
at an angle and received their own bit
of sunlight
we're done no math nothing necessary we
don't need to know fibonacci we don't
need to know
the golden uh ratio we don't need to
know any of that we need an explanation
that's called physics okay
okay so that's the difference between
math and physics right there okay
okay one file says says
i got kicked out of a sam
the structured atom model sam okay
club they are eu bunch the electric
universe
yeah because the electric universe just
like quantum mechanics no different by
the way between
electric universe and mathematical
physics why because they use
the quantum atom they use the little
ball
model of the arm they use the planetary
model and so they like sam because they
say oh we like it because
we can build a different atom that's a
little different than the one from
quantum
and actually they don't because how do
they build their atom
they build it with balls okay they have
a big ball called a proton ball
they have a little ball called the
electron ball and the only thing that
sam says is that one is negative the
other one is positive
and neutrons are made from the squashing
of these two
balls the big one in the little one and
then they build their
nucleus with many of these
both neutrons which are the merged
electron and proton
and protons that's the nucleus and
that's sam in a nutshell
so the sam model is absolute bunk
nonsense it's the same thing as quantum
mechanics they cannot do it with little
balls
as just explained throughout this
lecture and so
sam is no different than quantum
mechanics
we're done end of story okay
okay with that we'll see you on sunday
and remember that on sunday we're going
to have ons
on board you promised me he's coming
and so um we're going to open the floor
for real-time questions you can ask your
questions directly
and embarrass us and put us on the spot
and make us
feel uncomfortable all that good stuff
okay so that's your job
ask us questions that you want to
understand if we can answer on the spot
we'll do so otherwise we'll take a rain
check and answer it
next time with that i'll see you on
sunday